ha ha you know most of us are actually  watching our diet these days you look  like [ __ ] yeah  please don't part in my yoga class okay  it's okay it happens could you please  leave them come on come on bill  you're gonna need some new yoga pants  OOP you set the tree on fire can you  please keep the methane inside climate  change is a real problem  really  yeah it's because he's Indian it's not  because of his freakishly large monsoon  or you want you to have big emotions  damn it so the sense of topic are you  look at me this car hey you get are you  ready to start your new life focus today  you get your Hadouken  oh my Roux is back to his old self